what is up everybody how's it going
first things first I know things look a
little bit different right now and that
is because the entire company is on
mandatory work from home right now which
means I am doing the daily live streams
from home as well and honestly it's just
for everyone's safety make sure everyone
is you know staying healthy and we've
still got to do we got to do though
we're still gonna be playing these games
and hopefully trying to have fun still
in light of everything going on so thank
you guys so much for even joining up and
hanging out let me know how everything
is looking obviously my equipment at
home is not at the same tier as at work
but we're gonna do our best anyways and
hopefully have some fun today and
revisiting doom because next week do
eternal is coming out and that's gonna
be really exciting so yeah let me know
how it's looking how's it goin what up
Ritchie Brandon's back everybody else
Tara hello David hello and yeah you guys
are also working from home well stay
safe out there hope everything's stocked
up but yeah let me know it does
everything sound okay I'm gonna start a
fresh game here new slot it I'm probably
gonna go for the the harder difficulty
and see what happens see if I can if I
can withstand it but yeah hopefully
everything is running well I'm not sure
haven't gotten any feedback from you
guys yet
and I do apologize in advance you might
be hearing some sirens I do live in the
city soundproofing here does not exist
but you know what it's all good we're
gonna do our best right so yeah um let's
play I'm excited to revisit this because
it's been a long time since I played it
and to be fair when I did play it I was
playing with friends I didn't get to
catch the beginning at all so I kind of
got spoiler alerted maybe three quarters
into the game so let's go ahead and
start I'm excited
yes I am working from home the whole
office is working from home uh yeah
Bob Jones with it welcome back good to
see you everything sounds good alright
great that's all I needed to hear just
needed that confirmation because you
know it's always nerve-racking
everything's okay nice nice maysa all
right well this is either gonna be great
or horrible let's find out
with Intel can't wait for the manliest
most badass intro ever brain
honestly the way he displays smashes
affected
literally he's perfect way to start off
the heat
[Music]
yeah check out the gun real quick things
here know we're gonna rip and tear today
don't you worry we're doing it oh wait I
forgot
Audio is just a little high Oh on my mic
I can turn right down actually we have
to contain this
[Music]
I'll contain it all right
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah that's how I get dressed in the
morning to you know reorder doom it's
ritalin for my boyfriend watching this
to see if I should play it tacky now you
should play it why should he be the only
one to have all the fun
but that's awesome great gift I'm not
bad well this is literally just the
first five seconds you're gonna miss it
but ya know it this games really funny
like it
and from all the footage I've seen of do
eternal determinate very interested do
100% run oh I mean I'll try it but I
want to try to get as far as I can if
you guys tell me I just don't know where
everything is human animal crossing
great have you guys seen the doom kind
Isabelle like art and stuff everyone's
been doing oh my god
I love living for it to be honest these
pulldown yank this gun real quick oh my
gosh I've been playing so many different
games but all of my controls are
backwards right now damn I feel up soon
I believe so so we're definitely gonna
have a lot of cool doom stuff on top of
all the cool doom stuff we are already
right now
I wanted to trip him the the trip is
actually my favorite
[Music]
d my friends I forgot to activate this
first I was like what makes me laugh
about that first insist that like I'd
like to die so easily after that grand
entrance
thank you gives you oh hey watch up this
one oh my goodness I'm failing
I just want to trip it
ah no how dare you how dare you Oh keep
missing the legs
No
oh let's get through actually
yeah
everyone's gonna get their chests on
thin that's all that's all saving lives
get over here
No get off of that get down here yeah
and you dip your nose
find the resource audience is engaged
did I miss the opportunity to do that
well there goes the hunch person
stranded what is up there is your
shoutout thank you for joining us
joining me today
the first info screaming in fear not
trying to scare you
okay that makes sense actually who would
have thought who's actually the video
game to bring couples together invited
these two people mentioning playing it
was very significant and there is which
is super cool yeah I think this does out
all right Sam
coming for it coming for you
it's soundtrack it's so sick it really
gives me pumped up to like start ripping
people's head square it which I guess is
double
all right super here all night
last time I play this I did not play it
on this difficulty so I don't know if I
should be playing as if it's still just
as easy but
now oh yes I just said that didn't I I
just said that it's fine
see now I know that uh I need to be a
little bit more careful oh I know guys
shoutouts to Peter Brown he is moving on
to bigger and better things with himself
super and happy for him by the way but
it is very sad to just see him go
because everybody's so awesome
I feel like I did not pick that up the
first time anyway we out
okay my things need to be more mindful
of my health set of just being a ham
they don't want that
Oh
[Music]
I mean I kind of look for like this
though
wait get over here No
yeah
oh we just straight up night no
these guys
hey hey look I'm gonna need to cut it
out cut it out
Oh hands to yourself
I'll be new
Oh
what
yeah
[Music]
that everybody I am playing on ps4 right
now um the cool thing is actually is IPS
now and it's on PS now so if you guys
have peanuts now then oh how do I get up
there you guys help me out I just saw it
right now ding no all right you guys go
let me know how to get little where can
I hit
whoo yeah okay all right he's so cute
I want one of those I want one of those
IRL okay well we got him and we've got
the kicker yay he's so adorable
I know the G where you at can't wait for
do eternal
no deathmatch or team deathmatch mom
interesting
honestly I've just been watching
gameplay footage and stuff like that
others I definitely need research we're
about Oh take your own hand off and
smack you in the face with that's a
whole mood right there
yes that's actually not the one I want
it but oh my cumin I haven't gotten to
sweep out the legs there we go
that's the one right there my favor
Oh [ __ ] that elbow oh man you need to
relax buddy
screeching all right fine we'll stay
over there
[Music]
Hey Oh No get scratched up by you guys
right now just Hey where did I say yeah
you shot we there's like a secret
entrance somewhere I don't know you guys
I feel like I've already messed up on
this 100% run
oh yeah get the upgrade which upgrade do
you guys think is better for for right
here cuz the church one I've tried I
didn't even try the explosive Mount one
yet I feel like that one's probably
something better a bunch of a group up
right um
Brandon actually mentioning a community
Fridays although this is not technically
a community Friday I'm just stream right
now community Fridays will definitely go
on been and gel mousse they'll be
holding down community Fridays moving
forward from their homes since we're all
on mandatory work home so they yeah
thank you for the reminder there Brandon
you to this but yeah okay so also
there's like a 30-second delay between
the chat in the stream so I'm giving you
guys some time let me know you pick
charge burst explosive shot char I'm
kind of leaning towards explosive shot
because I don't feel like the tribe
Bruce is gonna be super useful right now
so yeah what do you guys think
are equal explosive it is we're doing it
thanks guys okay now can't get
too big for my britches here oh yeah
that's definitely the good ones out
he like water written out and then got
stunned
nope
okay out not like that
yeah
[Music]
we will determine for a second excuse
you excuse you try to beat that guy down
thank you very much wait
Oh
nope okay wait wait no
[Music]
we're not ready to run No
yeah I don't want this on my screen
anymore I'm trying to survive
would do anywhere else it's looking
rough no oh no okay yeah
eleven huh get off of that oh I knew it
I knew it yeah we've got a few people
holding down the streams from whom oh no
this is very great I like it yeah that's
pretty much
Dumon in that shell and it's getting
even better I don't know if you guys
have seen footage of doing my turn well
most of you have but for Carter I don't
know if you've seen some of the
all right we're out like there's stuff
yeah
just by the way up here
oh this is how I get up here
[Music]
little area
fire
yo
yeah
Oh Bonnie
nope
oh yeah that a fair comment
don't want to linger too long
No
yes brother
[ __ ] I am clearly
stop it Oh No
I'm gonna beat me down Lord
Oh
yes
No
[Music]
yes I like the green stuff I like
[Music]
I had all the goodies wait there's like
[Applause]
all righty then
oh all right we out
[Music]
boom we did it oh I missed some stuff oh
my bad
oh man all right so let's move on
honestly this game is just straight-up
carnage and like fun I'm just like turn
my brain off run forward start blasting
the shotgun although I'm take more
damage since the difficulty is a little
higher I have to cure a little bit dee
says I have to choose between neo - or a
doom eternal man that's a tough decision
I mean they're both pretty different
what is this sound that I keep hearing
in my headphones do you guys hear that
just me
alright let's continue shall we
this is the highest difficulty I could
do without beating the game as I'm
streaming this up yes now the sentient
intelligence assigned to ours after
running Diagnostics on the pressure suit
it appears that I can activate optional
challenges that when completed resistant
upgrading your arsenal at an accelerated
pace I have added a tracking component
pure dossier
you'll see you later Chris thanks for
tuning in
Oh
my shield is melted
Oh
[Music]
this game is best played with a steam
controller freedom honesty what's this
now what's the steam can what will be
your final moments in this world all
their enemas the human sacrifices
the demons it's true my sisters and
brothers be thankful you will be the
first you will have a seat alongside
them just as I will in what will become
the new world they create for us
starting on the chat here
can't wait for doom eternal heck yeah I
feel about the same Andrew just picked
this up on switch and replaying it nice
you know and what will be your final
notice in this world
yeah she can [ __ ]
oh that woke everyone up below
oh it's gonna play infinitely is it
really this those four making all that
annoyance wrong is the best controller
ever I gotta check it out because I just
listened playing more games on Steam no
that is now out oh I missed that
whoa No
oh that guy is was on fire
but hey assist meant help America's not
saving lives
yeah yes
Oh
[Music]
Oh
wait
okay
oh I knew that fire guy was there
okay
yeah
Mozza monix presents a lemonade this
game is just fine couse i just feel like
so overpowered all the time oh this is
where I should be going
looks pretty scary down there now good
Oh yep was it me that was that was
somebody else please don't make me do
the whole thing again that would be very
sad
oh wait I feel like I did not walk in
this roof last time - they put me right
in front of the room they were like here
long he's dumb enough to miss where to
go if we respawn you right
oh no not like this
okay there we go there we go
my then my bad
I was just delayed
yeah I guess that would have been more
fun to use against everybody instead of
just shooting I don't have access
like is that
purity oh I'm already on max pool he you
old
shiny
[Music]
now I really want people to come by
tonight
[Music]
well that was yeah I use it on some weak
little minions but why not aim to
support us being safe we indeed are
everyone is officially on mandatory work
from home which is why I am streaming
gamespot live from home now you know we
get worried back but burn things
everyone's safe and we want to keep it
that way so these are the measures to do
so but as long as you guys keep tuning
in and hanging out regardless of where
we're streaming from that's really all
we care about
oh wait I got it I just all the big boys
oh you want some dude yeah no you're not
worrying me as Mashhadi
oh I mean the chainsaw you definitely
shiny definitely
oh he
oh no I'm Emma
okay good luck am i going on
we shall continue to jump around jump
around okay when I got all these
fireballs
little Gary oh man Oh
yeah nice
whole
[Music]
oh man 43 Camry
anti-climatic that's right there you
didn't die but oh boy oh boy yeah No
got some light
right yeah we're good ain't no thing
[Music]
yeah I'm shining em right there
damn rough oh man I want to fight with
that you let me think I'm quite so
whatever that thing's fought the rich
right desperately need some shotty ammo
oh and back over here and it was their
own sweet yeah oh man there was shoddy
I'm done the whole time
okay get written we need but
Oh impatient I like how they let me
press the button again though I'm sorry
and presses the first time unleashing my
inner Harley Quinn yeah for sure I'm
like enjoying every every skull crushed
oh snap
alright guys you know what time it is oh
wait they just want me to
I guess I felt like I'm having been
using these very much but yeah all right
got the mo I'm kind of low okay yeah
thank you
they were listening to months available
for Weapon X which Lee quick lab a bit
the bit did the switch between them
pressing yeah
Oh does he have the key hey gimme yeah
good thing I was looking at you guys
instead of I was reading chat instead of
looking at that because I feel like it
would've low-key Gavi wait should I go
back
oh wow that guy straight up woke up
smack me for like 16
oh my
oh and oh this is the beginning
beginning oh wait
go back no this wasn't did real us don't
world is count there was that other room
for this much
let me
[Music]
it's on bloodied up - I mean it
obviously didn't do that guy too much
good cuz he's dead now but you know in a
more skilled hands
Oh
which is just to pick up the awareness
now mollies beginning to touch some
screen somewhere for a robot robot
I like
oh whoops
Dillon Slayers your first time enjoying
a stream well one I'm honored and - I
apologize I feel like a lot of stream
lines out there are very entertaining so
sorry you've run into streams you
haven't enjoyed take - let me not eat
tell me can I not
while I'm bad I'm bad and that's okay
I was trying to hit that red barrel and
the more I missed it the more it was
like wow I don't even want to live the
rest of this life just given Irish back
back into the action here are you guys
know right now usually I leave my window
open to get some airflow but I don't
want the outside noise to be too loud
that mixed with this gameplay right now
got me super sweaty
Wow oh that's cuz it wasn't a barrel it
was freakin no man and I'm going today
I'm silly silly goose
now
oh my goodness
Oh see health care it's good wait what
is that oh my goodness stuff someone I
know I didn't pick up the feel all right
this stage has kicked it up a notch
therefore I need to be play smarter I up
for real I like it's really hot but I'm
having fun so that's what it's all about
oh I have to every night
murder here
Oh
man I love the music
[Music]
don't earn men
come here buddy
Oh
shiny
wait
boy
Oh green stuff I'm on it sorry I need it
yeah all right now I'll bring it on
there's over here Oh
yelling in my ear over here
they got one hell of an arm
Jane what a homie you saw his friend was
stunned and he like ran away
Oh
ding by this rope okay
you know
oh there's more green stuff up there
I'm like mr. Krabs with the green stuff
heck yeah
one week until our salvation I know
honestly when I play this I'm already
like man this is fun this is good like
kind of stuff I really really like to
play and like how could it get better
you're bad I don't know from what I've
seen from doom eternal so far looks
definitely up my alley Wow I definitely
babies that dead guy's hand I'm blocking
your access to the facility scanner come
to the Vega terminal and he'll give you
what you need yeah sure
hold up
yes Akash with antair Philippa
oh wait not me where I'm walking Oh
everybody's back everybody's back
that other guy just like died by
associations
[Music]
get up I should have been able to climb
on
it's so windy all of a sudden
so weird sometimes
thank you
go back inside
I'm like trying to look at these markers
up top they're all
where is it oh snap I'm starting to see
some quick talk in the chat actually I
should have picked that up earlier that
would have been super bad
yeah I've played quake before but mostly
just because I like watching quakecon
and stuff like watching I level quake is
super cool I know I'll never be that
good but watching them pull it off it's
really cool just the movement I think is
so sick
it's really really cool um all right
yeah help
I I don't know where to go so I need to
go back inside close the airlock and
then
back of the elevator a green stuff
you'll how much fuel do I got pointing
to
[Music]
yeah
go back up the crane okay let's keep
trying to use square on that
right up the crane while this is the
cream right
is there another elevator I didn't see
all right hold up
oh oh oh oh now I see now I see thanks
guys thanks thanks thanks thanks mother
that's why they have the setup trying to
go somewhere they were trying to lead me
there with the bad guys
duh sorry it's Friday you know stopped
on green stuff
I haven't been looking out for little
doom diet
[Music]
oh you kind of hit me
animators Schiavi how would I rate my
employment at GameSpot to be honest like
this is my dream job and I love it so
much because you know I'm sure you guys
too growing up so many people are
telling me all my life
stop playing games grow up you know it's
never gonna take you anywhere so
honestly I'm just super thankful at
every single time locks it and yeah I
love it it's pretty great and everyone's
really cool I mean everyone I work with
it's amazing
BTS
they're young I was like which one of
these screens do I need to touch right
now oh hey hey
he's a tumble roll I'm trying to read
the chat buddy
I cannot believe you still hit me I made
it though and I'm streaming off games
like it's true it's true
and I'm just like ever honestly okay
even though I've almost been hearing
here now which is crazy on top of all
that I've almost been here a year and
every single day I'm still like I can't
believe it so I just got I just ripped
something off of this guy's body I
wasn't paying attention because you guys
got me and my feelings but
I'm stuck stop it
Muller everyone down
Wow oh my god
all right he'll played me right there I
can admit it I can admit it watching
well anything video has been interesting
I would imagine when we really are
trying to edit a video with like the
carnage of doom going on in the
background
oh thanks Brandon
[Music]
I want him to feel left out but yeah
thank ya come back next week for sure
because we're definitely playing some
eternal
hmmm rising fuel left in my chainsaw
oh yeah come here big boy
[Music]
although that other one yeah that other
ones the one that got me pretty bad
oh yeah let me actually see what I
ripped off the thing oh wait I already
took it right get out of here either all
right I'm gonna save that one uh that
one last bit of fuel I have for that
second shield guy
what headset am i using I think this
one's like a HyperX headset but I'm
actually using a Yeti for the mic not
this actual Mike this is like for show
right now all right let me stop being
him
really dude trying to hit me with those
moves
yo the mood yeah I have one proceed at
your own risk that's what you should be
telling these guys
Wow
come on come on looking like 3d over
here now she looks like you correct
alright so I save my I saved my last bit
of fuel for that shield viewed in the
hallway it's a little bit more compact
in there take it one step at a time you
know
[Music]
I'm lucky Oh Oh see see
no no and there's a box here re there in
all right yeah see I just I'm out of
fuel you know issue or else I would be
chopping them all the pieces like thanks
guys
error seen if they have some health
needs
it's a gift
yeah take it it will give you strength
help you on your journey feels like a
seed withstand the power surge
man his forearm beast okay okay um
what'd you guys think
help me pick help me pick health armor
Amma mind you there's about 30 second
delay between the stream and the chat so
I'm gonna give you guys a second I mean
usually for me in games in general that
give me these options I usually go for
health just goes I always want to make
sure I have a lot of health because I
need it the way that I play but you know
armor is kind of thorns and that to let
me know
this coloring around looks kind of doom
one like the the reddish color health
alright we already got one for health to
buzz for help
noise good then I feel like you guys are
on the same wavelength with me because
yeah that's what I'm thinking - alright
let's do it
what a bullet balls are welcome and
thank you for joining us video games
will unlock the remaining archerd cells
within the facility for do it do it now
60 1337 UAC members disease 81% of the
facility is on lockdown critical yeah it
seems that a hill wave was activated
transforming 64% of all UAC employees
into the creatures you see roaming
throughout the facility the rest vacuum
by the demons released from their
holding so as my Olivia Pierce I feel I
should apologize for what's happened
here some of my boys took things too far
Olivia was the cause of all this and
idly
you will have to deal with her in time
you may not agree with our research but
know this
we have saluted hell and its resources
because it was in mankind's best
interests to do so
[Music]
matters now there is an emergency in the
foundry the regulator's have been
destroyed and the core temperatures are
no good old pathfinding overrun the
adjacent facility if the venting
turbines aren't reengaged neither of us
will survive the meltdown can I go down
yeah
completed all right we did it
I definitely missed like all the secrets
right where I was not looking back
but yeah I think we might be able to get
another stage in before our time is up
for the day I'm hoping so but I'm having
an awesome time I hope you guys are
having an awesome time
happy Friday by the way we've made it to
the weekend
all right satellite is back on the full
scale and origin of the attack is
revealed why are we doing all the work
here
doom guy he has a lot of responsibility
on his shoulders
after running more Diagnostics on the
active crater suit it appears that I can
accelerate the upgrading of your arsenal
I measure my combat effectiveness I have
added a tracker if your helmets display
noise the facility will not allow you
access to the turbine room unless the
demonic threat level is brought down
inside the foundry our security systems
cannot be the gore nests is so
have to
I've not been using my pistol Mitch
since I got my assault rifle all right
help me level up doomed I got one point
in here area scanning and environments
little resistance that might be good
explosive damage these upgrades improve
equipment capacity but the speed may be
the environmental just in case you know
I don't want to get hit with some some
explosions
explosive barrel and environmental
damage to take in these weapons self
damage immune to explosive barrel down
those items over
oh I need to for that well yeah
we'll do some environmental resistance
and then as far as my upgrades go here
ooh a room is a reload time yeah sounds
good rapidfire yeah oh I need three for
that I need to pay the big bucks for
that one I might just hang on to a point
what's up
let's hop in mommy
oh there we go
tactical scope mic little missiles
yeah I'll do scope actually the missile
song gets you
all right you guys got a pic guys got a
thing hey thanks for subbing y'all every
sub and every like and every single
second year here actually means a lot to
us and it helps us out so much
appreciated
all right scope or missiles scope or
missiles who's it gonna be what's it
gonna be I was leaning through the scope
but the thought of unleashing missiles
onto somebody gets me excited so we're
gonna go
[Music]
[Music]
oh wait I shouldn't be trying to see
that
he's an explosive boy Wow okay feet up
by their own guy over there Oh
gas leak detected
like he is this guy's hands
wait not that guy since
[Music]
that doesn't sound good
Wow okay well
I didn't I pick up a blue key
cool temperatures man about the die from
the heat in the game
hurt hurt no cut it out
if you like the snow
that was fuel I'm constantly getting
psyched out
I definitely have the yellow card or if
it's my yellow card from lazarum dozy
cow the different yellow cards Ocean
Avenue
give me more help
loulou and it filled my home too
Oh
the side
started from this side of the lake
oh wait I started here
oh I'm on fire okay this is where the
guy walked into that area in the vision
well that's and I took out the other
night
No
Oh at least I didn't fall in love it
this is why I'm horrible at platformer
games say
there we go
there's the guy all right we have this
and then like I could make that jump me
again I'm under estimating doom guy here
under estimating oh and did this slide
with the sound down the good stop
[Applause]
[Music]
um probably not gonna play in the o2
today but we're definitely gonna get it
on the stream probably next week
I played um I played through neo to demo
that was out a couple months ago Souls
games man
her you know that style of game it's
very hard for me I mean you see how I
play I play like some nut
so in those games you have to actually
have some like self discipline something
I don't exactly upgrade stop giving it
rates up
[Music]
oh please
[Music]
all right 1cor nests demonise where's
Nana go get the rest of percent
so the other ones
I'm still tonight
9
there though oh okay wait your turn
whoa the friendly fire oh dang
No
No No
we almost I'll played me again that guy
always gets me really low on ammo scary
not something that I
oh I forgot we're on Lawrence right yep
I'm lying on ps4 actually it's on PS now
right now if you guys are interested or
if you have PS nails it is it is
available
well what am I missing here then I walk
from
like I did walk from this direction oh
no I'm getting lost uh yep
in case guys don't know my name's Persia
slavers
I definitely want me backwards
all right so I went to the right
I suppose a job down here
that is Alec safe
I mean when I play shooters on PC I tend
to play with the controller also oh
there we go I was like I definitely miss
something back there me hurt some racket
over there oh oh I'm not equipped
I was not equipped for that and yeah
about that
what up is then Darian how's it going oh
yeah the after dark podcast I love that
podcast
Entertainment is also doing their
podcasts now too which is really good
I'm running low I really don't have
enough for anything so I'm gonna oh I'm
gonna have to make a run for it
I gotta go oh my goodness I'm going to
die
[Music]
Oh oh my god I'm so I need that gun no
oh my god so I got enough time for this
guy he's not gonna come through there
right oh my god he got me good
he got me good with that one he's not
gonna lie no no
oh my gosh I'm so discombobulated now
because that was him get it out
green green green ice only 15 stop it
stop it right now
can you not there's - oh I did not know
that I did not know that
[Music]
I'm sorry but he got me good on that one
so low on ammo stock up here
[Music]
we're going to get more machine-gun
animal or plasma
whoo sorry I needed a moment to collect
my thoughts
okay there we go
alright let's go
[Applause]
Laser boy over there
[Music]
okay
No
Oh
tell me a little worrying just a little
bit demonic threat reduced by 50%
oh I got fuel finally I just want to try
to finish this level before we have to
sign off yeah
Oh
it goes to
when the slain
that we already went through here
where is the minion to tell me I'm
walking in the right direction
follow these markers at the tops feel
like I should
oh there's the work
yeah oh wait what was I looking at there
we go we got the blue card finally
[Applause]
okay
he just pops up out of nowhere
it's good real quick
[Music]
should be enough I guess we're gonna
find out
[Music]
where
oh you got there
my cousin music Todd is a little bit
now
big boy
oh whatever
the AoE
oh I should have chains on am i fuel now
we do missed opportunity 5% are out I'm
a chance all the next guy
[Music]
they're the ones over here yeah we are
almost
this level I think
oh there it is there it is service
whoa hey big boy no I got it
whoa the Twinkle Toes up here
oh I just jumped off this guy's got me
that shook that I straight-up jump into
the lava I loved all the way down nice
homage there oh man
got me good got me good
get some scared demonic threats we do
them off 75 percent need some ammo
I kind of got a bunch of amalong
everything already so
sweet Jesus honey
assault rifle and
oh wait no
the word
[Music]
all right come on all right as I got
three slices from my chainsaw left my
aunt my armor is maxed
when way
oh I'm doing too much right now
trying to conserve as much animal as I
can I really should not be using any of
my good guns right now all right settle
the one for a kick off the party wait
tell me there's some more animals just
yes where's big boy yet though
big boy is not here early early all
right
[Music]
[Applause]
wait where's big boy yet I have my
chainsaw right here ready
that felt way more difficult the first
time I came down here great well I'll
take it how are you better
come on there we go
running our up
[Music]
we want to go in here
can I use the chainsaw to cut nurse
go up again
where is it
that's correct but I can get this to our
last embrace oh yeah
all right now we can go through what
things are exploding line in the back
Oh something tells me
[Music]
again spicy
ah
like I shouldn't be on these
a
[Music]
I sleep so much a dam right there then
where's big boy yet you don't let me get
slices don't want to catch this are real
quick
want to play a game
Oh oh wait wait
yeah finally now that was satisfying but
oh I was like I know there's one
but the explode in here or something
whoa another wait
Oh
now that laser hurt where are they
Lock them in that fireball but whatever
we take those
[Music]
[Music]
Oh No
lasers too much Oh
Oh like Angela's over
oh hey oh I'm out of ammo hope y'all
game was a little more severe a little
bit
Oh mommy
no yes
I need
okay so King
ya can't catch you too fast
[Music]
oh there's still another one oh wow
you're so far in it hey
hey Robert right that had to be last
evening the music has calmness the cool
temperature is now stabilized yeah we
did that we stabilize this place stop
the meltdown authorization Bolivia Vince
4:02 yeah that got a little spicy salty
nuts how many died like twice two times
too many of us mayors
she is trying to tear open the portal
between our world
[Music]
man look at her suit
[Music]
so crazy you could not
well
she is under estimating our abilities
now sounds a bit good so you know I
ain't feeling it ain't about that life
the system won't allow anyone with
Olivia to override it now we will have
to shut down the Archer tower manually
from the surface
well you guys thank you so so much for
tuning in and hanging out with me today
that is gonna be all for today's
broadcast but like I mentioned earlier
in the stream company-wide we are work
from home at mandatory so that means all
of the gamespot live streams will also
be right here from my house and also
occasionally from John the convince
house to for community Fridays but even
though we're all supposed to be working
from home we're still here to bring all
of the GameSpot content you've grown to
love to you every single day so make
sure you're tuning back here you're
checking out our YouTube channel you're
coming by the website because we are
still in action everything is still in
motion and we're still doing our best to
bring you guys the best that we can so
thank you so much for tuning in super
appreciate everyone who stopped by and
yeah can't wait to see you guys tomorrow
just kidding on Monday because it's
Friday go enjoy your weekend you guys
alright peace out thanks so much and
catch you guys on Monday
you